y
[Música]
altos mandos del ejército estadounidense
llegaron a polonia para continuar con el
despliegue de la otan es cerca de
ucrania en respuesta a la presencia
militar rusa en la zona a lo largo del
día se espera el arribo de más efectivos
en tras el anuncio del presidente joe
biden de situar 3.000 soldados en europa
del este
canadá se prepara para una nueva ronda
de manifestaciones lideradas por los
conductores de camiones contra las
vacunas joven 19 en toronto la alcaldía
hizo un llamado a la movilización
pacífica y la policía cerró vías para
garantizar el acceso a los hospitales
y 62 mil familias afectadas se dejan
desde noviembre las fuertes lluvias y
deslizamientos de tierra en bolivia las
más recientes precipitaciones provocaron
el desbordamiento de ríos y derrumbes la
mayoría de los departamentos del país
continúan bajo alerta meteorológica
naranja
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y regreso con ustedes para más
noticias de fin de semana en france 24
iniciamos el informativo en polonia
llegaron al país altos mandos del
ejército de estadounidense como parte de
la estrategia de la otan para reforzar
su flanco oriental en respuesta a la
presencia militar de rusia cerca de la
frontera con ucrania más aviones de la
fuerza aérea enviados por washington el
deben aterrizar hoy con tropas
prometidas por el presidente joe biden
en europa del este el miércoles pasado
el mandatario anunció la llegada de
3.000 efectivos en los próximos días
se enviará a 1.700 soldados del ejército
de eeuu a polonia es una unidad de élite
de las fuerzas armadas debidamente
equipada y entrenada para llevar a cabo
tareas y misiones en todo el mundo
dentro de varias horas desde el anuncio
de la alerta me gustaría señalar que los
soldados de la división aerotransportada
82 son hombres con los que nuestros
soldados han cooperado muy a menudo
realizamos tareas juntos como parte de
misiones en el extranjero ya sea en irak
o en afganistán estamos también listos
para aceptar otra transferencia de
tropas estadounidenses de las fuerzas
armadas estamos esperando a ver qué pasa
en las próximas horas
en canadá una protesta de los
transportistas pesados contra los
mandatos de vacunas entro en su segunda
semana con varios plantones planeados
este sábado en las principales ciudades
del país el llamado convoy de la
libertad ha cerrado la capital
canadiense durante ocho días
a medida que el llamado convoy de la
libertad atrae críticas de la policía de
ottawa las protestas de los camioneros
por los mandatos de vacunas se están
extendiendo desde la capital canadiense
a otras ciudades este fin de semana en
toronto las fuerzas de seguridad
intentan frenar los cierres la protesta
comenzó hace una semana por el mandato
de la vacuna kobe 19 para cruzar la
frontera entre eeuu y canadá
algunos insisten en que el primer
ministro liberal ya está instruido sea
depuesto con el argumento de que excedió
su autoridad al imponer restricciones
contra la pandemia
el movimiento produce frustración entre
algunos residentes de ottawa el ruido de
bocinas y en algunos casos acoso las
autoridades siguen pidiendo a los
manifestantes que abandonen las calles
pido a los manifestantes ahora que han
presentado sus argumentos que regresen a
casa que apelen ante sus autoridades sus
representantes electos para que
continúen defendiendo sus puntos de
vista así es como hacemos las cosas en
canadá los organizadores del convoy de
la libertad habían recaudado unos 8
millones de dólares estadounidenses pero
el viernes la plataforma de donaciones
web go fund me eliminó la página de
recaudación de los manifestantes
argumentando violaciones en sus términos
de servicio
austrian se convirtió desde hoy en el
primer país de la unión europea donde es
obligatorio vacunarse contra kobe y 19
la medida pretende elevar la tasa de
inmunización una de las más bajas del
bloque con multas de hasta tres mil
seiscientos euros para quienes no
reciban las inyecciones quedan exentas
las embarazadas los menores de 18 años
las personas para las que la vacuna
suponga un riesgo
se hayan recuperado de la enfermedad en
los últimos 180 días
de hecho desafortunadamente no hemos
sido testigos de la gran afluencia que
esperábamos es más como unas pocas gotas
de lluvia la mayoría de las personas que
vienen reciben su segunda y tercera
dosis pero aún tenemos la esperanza de
que la gente se convenza solo puedo
apelar a ellos por favor vengan y
vacunen se
china reportó 45 nuevos positivos de
kobe 19 vinculados a los juegos
olímpicos las autoridades sanitarias
dijeron que nueve de los casos son
contagios locales y el resto son
importados de viajeros procedentes del
extranjero la mayoría fueron hallados en
shanghai de otra parte también se
informó de 60 casos asintomáticos que no
se suman a los confirmados
y en bolivia las intensas lluvias han
provocado el desbordamiento de ríos y
derrumbes en diferentes partes del país
la mayoría de los departamentos hoy
continúan con una alerta meteorológica
naranja con riesgo medio porque se prevé
que continúen las precipitaciones que
han dejado decenas de miles de familias
desplazadas informe de manuel a cano
más de 62 mil familias afectadas esa es
la cifra que el viceministerio de
defensa civil de bolivia calcula que ha
dejado el temporal de lluvias que azota
el país la ciudad de la paz ha sido una
de las más golpeadas en donde las
autoridades reportaron al menos un
fallecimiento y varios desaparecidos
en el barrio de los rosales al sur de la
capital múltiples casas quedaron
gravemente dañadas
anteanoche lo vi tan fuerte como arriba
ha bajado de aquel canaletas como una
destilación brecha así la dejó siembre
han votado no es a su estado grave no
hemos dormido dos noches no hay mas
tormes la alcaldía anunció que se
encuentra de muriendo de manera
controlada varias viviendas del barrio
que podrían colapsar debido a los
deslizamientos para cargas también a
navegación vean cómo es la alturas
pronunciadas
cuando
prácticamente nos dormimos hace tres
días
los daños causados por la lluvia se han
dado en ocho de los nueve departamentos
del país y la mayoría se encuentra en
alerta meteorológica naranja con riesgo
medio debido a que se prevee que las
lluvias continúen es que en este periodo
estamos sufriendo por el fenómeno en la
niña lo que está un poco
condicionando los eventos climatológicos
y se están caracterizando en su mayoría
por eventos muy cortos con una
intensidad extremadamente alta las
precipitaciones también han dejado 33
mil hectáreas de cultivos dañadas y
cerca de 700 53 viviendas afectadas en
perú el presidente pedro castillo
anunció una nueva recomposición de su
gabinete luego de los diversos
cuestionamientos en contra de varios
integrantes del último consejo de
ministros- juramentado del pasado 2 de
febrero en su mensaje castillo pidió al
congreso liderado por la oposición dar
prioridad a los más de 20 proyectos que
ha enviado el ejecutivo para solucionar
problemas del
el informe desde louis en mente zúrich
buscar miguel gr fue fugaz el tercer
gabinete nombrado por pedro castillo
tras haberlo juramentado el 2 de febrero
el jefe de estado anunció que una vez
más recompondrá su consejo de ministros
otra acción orientada a intentar
remediar la crisis política en la que
está sumida el ejecutivo he tomado la
decisión de recomponer el gabinete
ministerial
y estos cambios se harán teniendo en
cuenta la apertura
a las fuerzas políticas académicas y
profesionales del país esta se suma a
otras por las que ya ha atravesado
castillo desde su llegada al poder el 28
de julio tiene su origen en el
nombramiento de héctor para leer como
primer ministro
una figura criticada por la oposición y
por movimientos feministas que se
manifestaron en las calles de lima este
viernes señalan a valer de presuntamente
haber incurrido en actos de violencia
doméstica contra su hija y su hija
difunta esposa el congreso peruano
liderado por la oposición rechazó el 4
de febrero el pedido de valer para
solicitar su voto de confianza al tiempo
que según la prensa peruana crecieron
los cuestionamientos en contra del
ministro de cultura el ministro del
ambiente y la ministra de la mujer y
poblaciones vulnerables
y
a otras personas que también
[Música]
castillo prometió que el consejo de
ministros incluirá voces de diversos
sectores políticos un nuevo gabinete que
sería el cuarto nombrado en los pocos
más de seis meses en el cargo castillo
espera poder destrabar el juego político
y obtener la tan ansiada gobernabilidad
el mandatario invitó al congreso a dejar
de lado las confrontaciones y el
obstruccionismo y concentrarse en las
necesidades urgentes de la población
los rescatistas de marruecos en el norte
de áfrica dicen que están más cerca del
niño de cinco años atrapado en un pozo
desde el martes pasado sigue la
operación obstaculizada por
preocupaciones sobre la estabilidad del
suelo tras excavar 31 metros hacia abajo
en la noche de este viernes comenzaron a
abrir un túnel horizontal para llegar al
pequeño identificado como ryan quien
cayó a 32 metros de profundidad afuera
de su casa en el pueblo de y gran hasta
el momento recibe agua y oxígeno por una
cuerda
y han sido varios días para nosotros
tratando de salvar a este niño después
de que usamos todos los medios con los
voluntarios comenzamos la segunda fase
de excavación es un proceso muy difícil
debido a muchos problemas relacionados
con la naturaleza y el suelo en el sitio
sigue en france 24
[Música]